I'm alright how are you I'm good
congratulations on the movie um so are
you prepared I was not sure what to
expect going in and I'm like in the
second act to the film and I'm like
getting mad at your character for the
way that she's doing stuff and saying
stuff and I'm like are you prepared for
people to be like that with you with
this role oh well I
I hope I hope not I hope they're more
sophisticated than you are I listen
anytime you're in a movie with three
icons playing characters that are
beloved and held dearly in the final
movie of a trilogy that people have
loved and you play the one character
that they don't know anything about and
maybe seems like you're working against
the people that they love than that I
understand but if you really watch it in
a more sophisticated way you will see
that I'm actually trying to help them
100 percent hundred percent trying to
help them absolutely uh this is one of
these films where there's so much I want
to talk about that I cannot I know this
is the story of my life I mean that's
like I don't know why we're doing this
this is with American Horror Story this
is with everything I do it's like well I
can't tell you right exactly you can ask
me that but I can't answer you there's
no spoilers that I would ever do but
which is good cuz that would be terrible
for people who don't want to have the
movie ruined 100% but I am curious how
much did Knight tell you about the
entire arc of this movie versus how much
were you reading it on the script for
the first time in like oh my oh oh it
was reading it in the script for the
first time when I first met with him he
said to me first of all I don't know if
this part is gonna be played by a man or
a woman I don't know if dr. staples
gonna be a man or a woman and I was like
well then what are we doing he's like
well maybe a woman and maybe it would be
you and I was like well I think that's
what it should be but I can't tell you
what to do because we're I'm not sure um
but it wasn't it - he told me you know
that the character was a psychiatrist
and she specialized in in patients who
had this particular disorder believing
they were superheroes and that was sort
of it that's all he told me so when I
read it I mean for all I knew I was
gonna be you know in one scene being
like y'all are nuts
and I gotta go Thanks so I didn't know
what exactly it was gonna be and I
certainly didn't know about the ending
until I read it I yeah I think there's a
lot to talk about we'd like to talk
about which we can do in a few months
when people reason or yeah but I mean
like is everyone gonna see it in three
days like I don't want to ruin it for
everybody even completely I'm not I
definitely wanted something we can talk
about though is there's a great scene of
you Bruce James Sam all in one scene
together in the hospital on a hot pink
room yeah let's not forget that uh what
is it like though that's just I mean
these are three great actors you're a
great actor what is it like the night
before you're gonna film something like
that are you like in your head a little
bit more are you in my head when I was
doing it it was like this is crazy
that's James McAvoy and that's Bruce
Willis and that is Samuel Jackson and
that is crazy and that would be enough
on its own but then you have them that's
Elijah price I'm Kevin crumb and David
Dunn these characters that I myself have
have loved you know watching their
stories in these movies so it was an
out-of-body surreal experience and then
there I am in the scene having to have
an air of authority and seeming somewhat
competent and it was and I had to talk a
lot so it was simple you know it was it
was not an easy day in the night before
I was just not sleeping and staring at
the ceiling thinking how am I gonna do
this how am I gonna pull this off um you
did very well I think you're cold what
we call a talented actor oh right
but in quotes in quotes I like the
challenge actor quotes I got talented I
gotta go um but Sussie congrats and I
can't wait to see what people think okay
you